[Música]
llevo más de 20 años recorriendo américa
latina'
tengo la fortuna de conocer de haber
estado pasar tiempo en todos y cada uno
de los países del continente todos los
de habla hispana es lo único que me
faltó que me falta todavía es cuba nunca
me invitaron pero muchos de los de habla
inglesa obviamente tope el el grueso del
continente lo conozco bastante bien lo
he recorrido lo sigo recorriendo que
recurrentemente
y la
la pregunta que se me fue formando con
el tiempo no porque latinoamérica
permanece siendo pobre porque
latinoamérica es pobre cuando el resto o
muchas partes del planeta han despegado
están despegando están en pleno
desarrollo porque en latinoamérica a
pesar de que queremos y constantemente
estamos buscando insertarnos en el
camino al desarrollo es el discurso de
siempre aún estamos todavía muy lejos
evidentemente y lo vamos a ver de
insertarnos en el camino al desarrollo
de ustedes se pueden a pensar
en otras partes del mundo en este
momento en muchas partes del mundo en
este momento se habla de la nube se
habla de la internet de las cosas se
habla de los drones que van y te dejan
los paquetes a la casa se habla de los
automóviles que se manejan solos
etcétera el internet de las cosas aquí
en américa latina' seguimos hablando del
precio del maíz seguimos hablando del
precio del frijol seguimos hablando del
precio de la soja del petróleo
entonces en muchos sentidos estamos
décadas atrás de muchas partes del mundo
qué es lo que nos hace falta primero que
nada lo que yo voy a establecer aquí no
es ningún el hilo negro no vengo yo a
plantear algo yo una reflexión propia
una investigación que dice no
simplemente es y lo que propongo aquí es
hacer en américa latina lo que todos los
países desarrollados o que están en vías
de desarrollo en este momento han hecho
porque está esta es la esta es la última
noticia todos los países desarrollados o
que están en la vida de desarrollo todos
lo han hecho igual exactamente igual
no hay alguien que lo haya hecho
diferente todo han hecho de la misma
manera y lo único que digo acá es vamos
a hacer exactamente lo mismo que están
haciendo todos eso es todo
y la clave son reformas tenemos que
hacer reformas económicas grandes
reformas económicas es muy interesante
voy a explicar un poquito de manera
rápida cómo que como los
latinoamericanos tenemos mucha
experiencia haciendo reformas hemos
hecho grandes reformas económicas que
explican la circunstancia en la que está
latinoamerica en este momento que es una
muy buena circunstancia muchos ustedes
son muy jóvenes no se acordarán pero los
que leen historia y los que tienen un
poco más de 40 años de edad se acordarán
que américa latina durante el siglo 20
tuvo fue un siglo de crisis recurrentes
américa latina tenía esta ciclos de
crisis con inflación con espirales
inflacionarias y cristo otra vez que
decíamos 67 años y la otra vez crisis y
crisis y crisis todavía la necesidad muy
clara de tener que hacer algo porque
estas crisis eran absolutamente
terribles y estoy hablando de
latinoamérica en general no finalmente
en los 80s después de una gran crisis
que hubo en méxico estoy concretamente
en el 82 que afectó al resto de la
de américa latina' costa rica tuvo una
crisis muy fuerte en ese momento se
empezaron a tomar lo que yo le llamo la
primera generación de reformas
económicas en el continente que fueron
aquellas reformas que después se les
llamó de manera peyorativa y que todavía
se les llama mayor manera peyorativa el
neoliberalismo típicamente los estados
muy inflados los estados de
latinoamérica tenían todo tipo de
incursión en la economía había incluso
empresas de bicicletas que eran
propiedad de los estados etcétera los
estados los gobiernos empezaron a
achicar empezaron a privatizar etcétera
una serie de reformas importantes con la
esperanza de poder llegar con la clave
de eliminar las crisis que teníamos
nosotros recurrentemente nuestra américa
latina'
desafortunadamente la implementación o
mala implementación de estas reformas de
desafortunadamente no solamente no
hicieron el efecto deseado sino que
encima fueron determinantes coadyuvaron
a la gravedad de la severidad de las
siguientes crisis que se dieron
concretamente en mexico de nuevo en 1994
95 el efecto
y algunos de ustedes conocerán osaban y
la madre de todas las crisis la
argentina 1999-2000 que no se puede
explicar la severidad sin el efecto de
la primera generación de reformas
económicas pero a partir de esas grandes
crisis que tuvimos tremendas espantosas
y espeluznantes a finales del siglo
pasado y principios de éste es donde se
concretan la segunda generación de
reformas económicas que junto con la
primera explica en el momento en el que
estamos en qué momento estamos llevamos
20 años en américa latina donde ya o 19
todo el siglo 21 donde ya no hemos
tenido crisis económicas esto es
histórico en la región no tenemos una
sola crisis económica en más de 20 años
venezuela es otro planeta
tampoco tenemos inflación en américa
latina y eso es eso es eso y lo logramos
nosotros con reformas económicas que
reformas se hicieron en la segunda
generación a partir de en los inicios de
este siglo y finales del siglo pasado en
américa latina eran reformas con tres
objetivos fundamentales toda la región
las tomó fueron reformas encaminadas a
tomar medidas fiscales contracíclicas
américa latina se hacen sea sincero se
disciplinó fiscalmente empezamos a
ahorrar dinero para poder ahorrar dinero
durante el crecimiento para poderlo
gastar los estados durante las épocas de
crisis
después podemos hablar si costa rica en
particular como este tipo de medidas o
no pero el resto de américa latina sí
hubo reformas encaminadas a liberar los
tipos de cambio fundamental en toda
américa latina prácticamente los tipos
de cambio son libres libre flotación de
las monedas el dólar se compra oferta y
demanda 100% gran parte de los ataques
que nos llegaban a nosotros que nos
causaban las crisis nos llegaba por
medio de un ataque a nuestras monedas
los fab los bancos centrales dijeron ya
sabes qué moneda defiende tu sola y ha
funcionado de manera espectacular y otra
medida muy importante costa rica también
atención en los el resto de américa
latina se desecharon por completo
básicamente los créditos en dólares
también empezaron a hacer créditos en
monedas nacionales
este tipo de reformas junto con la
primera es la que nos trae al momento en
el que estamos en este que es un muy
buen momento histórico para toda américa
latina por lo que acaba de mencionar sin
embargo seguimos en la pobreza hicimos
muy bien en deshacernos de las crisis
económicas muy bien deshacernos de la
inflación pero nos falta el crecimiento
nos falta el desarrollo económico
necesitamos una tercera generación de
reformas económicas por decir lo menos
que eso es lo que están haciendo los
países del mundo qué tipo de reformas
económicas necesitamos en este punto en
nuestra américa latina' reformas
económicas encaminados en tres puntos es
que todo esto de nuevo todo esto todos
los países lo han hecho ya tres reformas
tres elementos tres reformas económicas
dirigidas a tres puntos fundamentales
primero la plena utilización de la mano
de obra
y eso es importantísimo a mí me gusta
decir este ejemplo en américa latina'
si nos ponemos a pensar en américa
latina' realmente no usamos nuestras
manos los latinoamericanos no trabajamos
la que trabaja en la tierra
latinoamérica primariamente produce lo
que produce la tierra
emiliano zapata el revolucionario
mexicano decía su grito revolucionario
la tierra es de quien la trabaja yo lo
que digo es que en américa latina la
tierra es la que trabaja
en la forma de lo que nos producen las
materias primas tenemos que utilizar
nuestra mano de obra no utilizamos en
américa latina' somos muy buenos para
utilizar nuestras materias primas pero
no utilizamos nuestra materia prima
principal que es la mano del
latinoamericano
fíjense china las reformas que como que
ha visto china china es una potencia
manufacturera alemania es una potencia
manufacturera en américa latina fuera de
méxico hablando de manufactura no hay
otro país que realmente se ha dedicado a
la manufactura poner a su gente a
trabajar y ni siquiera digo que méxico
lo haga de manera plenamente eficiente
reformas encaminadas a un segundo
objetivo acumulación de capital
acumulación de capital físico nosotros
con nuestras reformas solidificamos
nuestros sistemas bancarios tenemos un
sistema bancario un sistema financiero
muy sólido en américa latina'
no ha habido un solo quiebre de banco ya
en varias décadas en américa latina'
cuando antes las crisis y los ataques
nos venían por medio de corridas
bancarias y ustedes se acordarán hemos
solidificado absolutamente eso fíjense
que también no solidificamos con las
reformas que logramos hacer que cuando
eeuu y europa cayeron de rodillas en
crisis económica en américa latina'
básica básicamente no nos pasó nada si
acaso tuvimos una breve recesión en
algunos países y listo se acabó
fíjense la bondad de las reformas
económicas entonces decía yo acumular
capital físico nuestra capacidad de
ahorro nuestro nivel de ahorro en
nuestros países es paupérrimo es
demasiado pequeño
necesitamos aumentarlo
necesitamos ya solidificamos los
sistemas financieros eso es muy bueno
eso es básico pero ahora necesitamos
diversificar los necesitamos que la
gente tenga acceso no a la banca que ya
la tiene sino acceso a los productos
sofisticados de la banca hay muy poca
bancarización en américa latina en
particular en general y esa pero esa
poca bancarización que hay la gran
mayoría de los clientes son
cuentahabientes de cheques o de ahorros
la gente en general en su gran masa no
tiene acceso primero que nada créditos
los créditos son fundamentales para
poder emprender que muchos he hablado
aquí este día de eso no hay créditos es
casi imposible para un emprendedor
conseguir un crédito pero no nada más
eso no hay acceso a instrumentos más
sofisticados como acciones o como bonos
etcétera de nuevo la gran parte de la
bancarización es se limita a cuentas de
ahorros y cuentas de cheques y eso no es
no ayuda al desarrollo de un país
y un tercer elemento de las reformas que
estamos tratando de impulsar que
deberíamos de impulsar a aumentar la
productividad los latinoamericanos somos
tremendamente poco productivos y aquí
mucho tiene que ver la educación
superior productividad educación
superior nuestra educación superior
a nivel mundial es de muy baja calidad
tenemos muy buenas universidades pero
que no compiten a nivel internacional a
nivel mundial no es casualidad que si
ustedes van a eeuu y esto es real y
estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes han
estado en eeuu en nuestra universidad en
cualquiera de las unidades que estaban
en eeuu gran componente de la población
estudiantil de cualquier universidad
siendo eeuu todavía la cabeza del mundo
en el sentido del cerebro siendo el
centro de educación de excelencia del
mundo sigue siendo estados unidos y gran
componente de los estudiantes de las
universidades de eeuu son estudiantes de
la india y de china
y solamente una pequeña fracción son
latinoamericanos muy pequeña fracción
porque porque los estudiantes de la
india y la china salen del colegio del
bachiller del high school listos para
acceder a la mejor educación del mundo
que es la de eeuu
acá en américa latina' alguien que
estudia en la mejor escuela privada de
américa latina' aún así tiene muy pocas
oportunidades de acceder a una
universidad en estados unidos por por
sus promedios por sus calificaciones
entonces mientras no empezamos a
arreglar este asunto no vamos a poder
nosotros equipararnos con el mundo o
competir con el mundo como está
compitiendo en este momento decía yo la
productividad tiene que ver mucho con la
educación superior
decía yo que los latinoamericanos
utilizamos muchísimo nuestras nuestras
materias primas no utilizamos la mano de
obra no utilizamos nuestras manos como
materia prima pero tampoco utilizamos la
materia prima más abundante y limitada
que tenemos los latinoamericanos que es
el cerebro
no innovamos no inventamos no creamos
cuantos steve jobs cuantos bill gates no
han nacido en américa latina y no han
podido desarrollarse porque no están en
el ambiente correcto
estoy seguro que muchísimos
y voy a concluir diciendo esta no es
desafortunadamente una charla
propositiva puesto que yo no veo y yo
les pido a ustedes si ustedes lo ven el
momento no no veo a américa latina cerca
de estar
pensando o ejecutando este tipo de
reformas todavía yo no veo a américa
latina en un camino claro por eso es que
se llama el continente dormido estamos
dormidos todavía mientras que el resto
del mundo está bastante despierto
nosotros todavía no el problema que
tenemos es este este tipo de cosas que
estoy diciendo se discuten y se han
discutido recurrentemente en las casas
presidenciales yo creo que los
presidentes que están sentados la tienen
muy clara los presidentes del país
hablan de estos términos que yo estoy
hablando los presidentes de los países
latinoamericanos el problema siempre ha
sido a la hora de hacer la política a la
hora de negociar lo a la hora de hacerlo
con el congreso y la realidad de las
cosas es que nuestra historia estas
reformas que nosotros hemos hecho las
hemos hecho con la mano en el cuello las
hemos hecho en épocas de crisis
espantosas lo que no hemos logrado es
poder avanzar en época de paz digámoslo
así y ahí es donde nos ha fallado la
clase política y yo veo con mucho
pesimismo lo que está sucediendo hemos
probado en américa latina' de todo hemos
probado democracia hemos probado
dictadura hemos probado izquierda hemos
probado derecha populismo y estamos
básicamente en el mismo
donde siempre muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]